it's more affordable okay there's the
smell
yep that's budget hi I'm Alex and I love
cooking and history throughout history
there have been hundreds of food trends
that have come and gone today I'm gonna
be trying out one of these recipes and
seeing if it's edible okay
boy stur and chicken pie it's very vague
very underseasoned seems a little random
and weird I feel like when you see a pie
like a chicken pot pie it's really like
comforting and warm and inviting if I go
into this pie I'd be very disappointed I
guess I'm just gonna go line by line the
first thing to do is parboil a chicken I
have no idea how much chicken I'm
supposed to boil but I have I guess four
breasts right here so well that like
that it immediately turns white I'm also
gonna be hard boiling two eggs at the
same time nice chicken water in here
which is pretty foul it looks a little
like human flesh we're off to a good
start here yeah sure
I guess yeah actually I sirs are an
aphrodisiac so I guess everyone's really
horny back in the day cool down a little
before I peel them and then we're gonna
cut up this partially cooked chicken
they're looking nice and white over this
place oh great we're at the oyster part
so over this chicken place one pint of
oysters does it say to drain them but
I'm going to because I don't know if I'd
want to pour like oyster juice all over
this section product may contain shell
fragments that's just dangerous oh okay
I'm just gonna air it out I'm not even
exaggerating that is so strong okay all
right next if I can make it add two
hard-boiled eggs cut into small pieces
whoever invented this recipe was like
what else can we put on top of this but
at least it adds like a nice pop of
color I guess a tablespoon full of
butter do I just put it in the middle
like or am I supposed to cut it up like
there's no internet in these days so you
would think that they would be more
details with the recipes I guess I'm
just gonna cut the tablespoon up and
like put it in each bird some celery
chopped fine what is some celery
I'm guessing it's more than one sock
less than three
[Music]
we're gonna put this finely chopped
celery on top celery is also very bland
it's basically water
[Music]
yikes
that sounds like a problem yeah I can't
wait to eat this now now for the
seasoning
they say salt and cayenne which is a
little bizarre I don't want to get too
heavy-handed with this guy right now but
actually maybe I should I prefer my
mouth be numb when I bite into this yeah
this is actually the most confusing part
moisten with flour and a Gill of milk so
don't know what a Gill of milk is I
fortunately am NOT from the nineteen
tens and I have a cellphone so I'm gonna
look up what a Gill of milk is okay it's
a half a cup I guess just gonna go for
it so it's like a half cup okay I'm
assuming I have to stir it up because I
feel like that would be really bizarre
the milk at the bottom is now like the
oyster chicken juice water put the puff
paste on top they don't call it pop a
pastry they call it puff paste so I
guess in the nineteen times you have to
make your own puff pastry but that's
like really [ __ ] hard so I will not
be doing that maybe I'll use these
scraps make a little design on top I
feel like I should make an oyster design
just so people know what they're getting
into my oyster kind of looks like a
vagina so I'm gonna do an egg wash on
this even though it doesn't say that in
the recipe I want this to at least look
pretty if it's not going to taste very
good also they didn't tell us how hot
the oven should be forty minutes in a
moderate oven I'm gonna say moderate is
350
all right so it's been 40 minutes was
the fastest 40 minutes of my life
so now I have to try this by something
I've been dreading
[Music]
how about gonna be oh oh oh ma'am I need
someone else to try this though because
I don't know if it just mean like I
don't really like oysters that much I
don't think it's that bad
I'm kind of into it Oh the whip is not
promising yeah I can't say that's a
pleasant smell I wouldn't go out of my
way to eat this but I wouldn't stop
eating it if I was being polite just a
horn it's not totally offensive or
undelicious they're potatoes in here
it tastes like if I was a character in
SpongeBob SquarePants and I just
adjusted like all of the ocean I don't
hate it say that no it's not it's not
good like I don't understand why any of
this being together was necessary in any
capacity it's a taste that some people
might prefer and we don't flavor shame
if you didn't know tastebuds you might
think hey this is probably a pretty good
pie like the ingredients were held
together by Elmer's glue there's a
little bit hard to eat to be honest
[Music]
you
[Music]